right so high in order to do this in
order to prove that we satisfy this
differential equation what are we gonna
have to do what I do to get from a
function to its derivative we're gonna
have to differentiate right to
differentiate differentiate we'll get
this to a difference in the patient so
I'm gonna say if he really was this if T
was 20 plus let's say Aryans suggestion
here is there reason why it doesn't what
if I subtract 20 from both signs t minus
20 I have this okay now we might as well
do it with this if I differentiate the
left hand side as it is right now what
happens that big in 20 what happens when
you differentiate closer so this guy's
going to go when I differentiate this
with respect to time I'm just going to
get DT pullin DT Saturday differentiate
that right hand side for me that egg is
just gonna hang around what's going to
happen when you do the inside derivative
of that function and then of course when
you differentiate makes mitchell devil
the outside function not being happens
just so when you have a look at this
that a TV e to the minus KT is what I
have in the previous life let me just
make that a little clearer by
factorizing you knew you came like so
that's the very suggestion I have now
that's the team of 20 that I saw before
duskies I have sure it satisfies the
given differential equation you have to
do that so far so you different check it
looks good now we wouldn't use it
okay now you're never in the original
question
you got given all these conditions
these pieces of information yeah right
so what we want to do is use them in
some way to help us get huh be how do
you think I'm going to use this back to
you other than five minutes you're a cup
of coffee or whatever and you're
pointing it's now seven degrees yeah so
the exercise thing here the exercise
you've just been doing has said but in
the grey thread find out what K is right
and it will involve some weird logs and
that kind of thing because if you don't
know what K is you don't know how fast
it's cooling down right but this piece
of information can help you identify how
fast it's coming up right so where am I
going to put this into which equation in
order to do business as usual which one
yeah the first one is interested it's
not the temperature and it's got excited
okay so I'm gonna say if I take this
equation here I'm gonna substitute
seventy into the temperature and five
into the time can you go ahead and do
that and then try and work out what K is
can you get an answer okay I'll give you
some time well I do know that more as
well
[Applause]
this is music alright hey going are you
happy with this now you may not have
this exact thing written down in the way
in the vault that I forgive you my for
example have written it - in long 5 mm
egg and that's the same thing let me
right now viciously you can see why is
it that these two things are so what
about you yeah so I used the power long
way you're working with walks if you
could number at the front you can make
it the power of what you're taking a
bomb on right so I opted to step right
in there you sign up here I put that in
is up this to the power negative one
which of course is a reciprocal okay now
do you have to do that
maybe vote oh why do I do it two reasons
number one I don't like negative science
so I try to get rid of as quickly as I
can have you how quickly
have you already noticed that negative
signs other cause of like half of your
problems okay you're like I everything
was fine
why is like it's great and it's up
you've got a negatives but was there
secondly I like that it helps me like I
want to write this in the synthesis for
that I can't proceed it really is not
necessary thirdly I'm just using almost
I'd like to use a lot more syrup might
be a workable clothes are and you're
going to do this celebration a whole lot
like you can see if I changed all of
these numbers
suppose it took four minutes instead of
five to get to this temperature or
suppose I was going to some other number
related to some other kind of scenario
you're still gonna more or less go
through this same set of operations you
will almost always have a fracture yeah
you're doing log off whatever so you
might as well get good I've seen being
asked to find a attention but if you
think about it if I have enough other
information there's no reason why can't
I come back to that point later on all
right now why don't you go to find a
cave what was the point
this is the real question right but I'm
going to use that particular value K to
now solve for this when this is capital
T okay so they gave a million x-men
original equation I think I've just no
space and I'm gonna say well 25
represents a capital T and I've got the
rest of the equation here now because of
the way that K is is this gross awkward
number I'm actually not going to what
the value K even though I know what K is
okay because I'm just gonna have to
write one two three four five six
symbols over and over again the same
state symbols remember again all the way
until the last line and then it's just
gonna be not gonna work it doesn't
really help me to write this down each
time I might as you just put it in
whatever that you solve anything
so I'm going to suggest this as a finite
point just because K you know what it is
it will come to play later let me just
do the rearrangement okay so I'm gonna
take away from both sides I'm going to
divide by this I'm gonna take logs on
both sides and then I'm going to make T
the subject okay now at this point now
I'm actually ready to write it down
because I'm preparing to punch it into a
calculator okay so you can see that
division by minus sign over there
all 16 of the top and also dividing by
this K visit so that's gonna be one the
denominator okay right now n is a handy
thing because number one's faster number
two is our reminder for you in your
calculator not to punch the log2 process
press this down is going to give you
them up there's someone I can I have a
couple of that's what this has been
twenty nine point five zero it's for
more than some other stuff around sup
doesn't it
so this is my time twenty nine and a
half one units minutes does that seem
reasonable
it took five digits two o'clock thirty
degrees in temperature I am trying to
drop another forty five degrees does it
stand to reason that it takes almost
half an hour for that to happen and I
think it does can speak about this
always going to do a sense just right 25
degrees is that closely farm at ambient
temperature clue so far I'd say it's
pretty close right that the closer you
get to your ambient temperature or
ambient whatever the slower it goes
that's the way exponential decay goes it
slows right down so it's gonna take a
long time to move those last few degrees
does that make sense